[Music]
[Applause]
albert brier senior nfl reporter we
always love having him on he makes us
smarter every time he joins us aaron
donald uh revised contract 95 million
over the first three years that's up
from 55 million on his old deal
65 million in 2022 and 2023 all
guaranteed
and i don't know what leverage he had
here albert but that's a pretty good
deal for aaron donald
uh yeah i i don't think there's any
question by the way like it's pretty
fishy i always find when a press
conference is difficult to
find like for if it's hard for you guys
to find the press conference there's
probably some weird stuff going on right
because isn't the whole idea of a press
conference to
publicize something to get press
right right so
i don't know i thought i'd throw my two
cents in on that um yeah i mean like
it's a it's a groundbreaking deal in a
lot of different ways there's no
question about it
you know i i think the fact that there
are no new years on it is really the big
one because
generally when you're doing a deal like
this where a player has multiple years
the trade-off is the team gets control
on the back end and that's not what this
is this is like a straight 40 million
dollar raise and you asked about
leverage well i think there are two
things to look at here
number one i was talking to an executive
for another team about the deal
yesterday
and he said the key is that they don't
have to worry about preston the rams
don't because he's one of one there's
only one aaron donald there's nobody
like this nobody else can go back to the
table and say you did this for aaron
aaron's different
you know and then i think number two
is
sort of the position that rams were in
was
do we want him on our team or not and if
he was really willing to retire which
he'd been rumbling about for four months
like yeah you can draw a hard line and
say we did this deal we have you under
contract for the next three years we're
going to hold you to it
but if that means he walks away then
you're without aaron donald
with a team full of players in their
prime that's you know very much built in
a win now sort of way
and so i think those two things are the
key you know number one not really
having to worry as much about precedent
because there isn't another aaron donald
out there
and you can basically say to other
players we did this for aaron and aaron
alone
and then number two
it's just the prospect of not having him
on your roster versus you know what he
can do for you with the sort of roster
that you have right now if you're la are
there parallels with the lakers in the
rams that
it's all about
now winning and you spend all this money
they got rid of all their draft picks
the lakers don't have any draft picks
now it worked for the rams it worked for
the rams or the lakers a couple of years
ago but
this i
there seemed to be two schools of
thought golden state and the celtics
built their teams via the draft
you know the rams said hey we don't care
about that we'll go out and buy whatever
we need to buy we'll make a trade you
know for uh our quarterback
but that philosophy with the nfl it's a
copycat league albert
do you see teams trying to build through
the draft or they want that quick fix
like what the rams did oh no i think
you're seeing like a lot of teams
reacting um to what the rams have done
and i think the biggest
way you're seeing it is teams are seeing
draft capitals being disposable now you
know forever and ever and ever
like the first round pick was sort of
this you know holy grail of of of nfl
currency
and you know
it was kind you know it's common that
you would trade first round picks away
for quarterbacks but now you see teams
doing it in other positions too you see
you know the
the rams did it with jalen ramsey and
and matthew stafford of course you know
now you see the raiders doing it with
devante adams you see the dolphins doing
with tyree kill so
you know you i think one of the main
ways in which the rams are influencing
the rest of the nfl
is they are
showing other teams like that there's a
different way to look at the value of a
first-round pick
um and so i think that that's a big
piece of it and that's some of the that
influence we're seeing across the nfl
remember there were eight teams this
year that didn't have first-round picks
and i i think that's a direct result of
the rams sort of
ability to win this way devaluing what
first round picks are in the league
because teams are more willing to move
them and then i think the second piece
of it is you you do see
because of a um sean mcvay giving them a
chance to win every single year the same
way bill belichick gives the patriots a
chance gave the patriots for 20 years a
chance to win every single year and you
can throw tom brady in that matthew
stafford for the rams the feeling that
because we have sean mcvay because we
have matthew stafford because we've
shown we can win on a consistent basis
and then because we're in los angeles a
desirable location
even if we have some holes on our roster
as a result of this
we're a desirable location so we're
going to be able to get guys who are
going to come in and want a gravy
trainer ring and you know last year that
was odell beckham and odell beckham
before he goes down in the super bowl
plays a major role for them they paid
next to nothing for him you know and so
they also have this back end benefit
where
they can spend draft capital and money
on their top players
and then
you know you got to hit on some of your
draft picks there's no question about
that unless need his department have
done a good job of that but also you've
got the ability to sort of spackle some
holes because people genuinely want to
play there and are willing to come there
for less if you could only add one for
the same price
aaron donald or cooper cup
oh aaron donald i like it's not a
question for me like i i was i think
the interesting thing about the receiver
position dan
do you see who traded away receivers
this offseason yeah the chiefs and the
packers those aren't stupid teams you
know what i mean like this isn't like
the detroit lions no offense to dan
campbell and brad holmes who i think
have done a good job there but like this
isn't like this isn't some team that
hasn't won in 20 years trading receivers
away on the other end of these deals
right like so and that
like look i understand why the raiders
did it with adams i understand why the
dolphins did it with hill and the
packers and chiefs did give
representative offers
to
adams and hill respectively but they
were also willing to move on from them
while they're paying other positions and
part of it was the packers had a corner
to pay so now they've paid jair
alexander the chiefs have a left tackle
to pay they're going to pay orlando
brown
and so you know when the price tag has
gone up
on their
on their quarterbacks right like so you
know patrick mahomes and aaron rodgers
the price went up so you've got to cut
corners other places
where did those teams choose to cut
corners they actually were okay cutting
a corner at receiver because the amount
of receivers that are coming into the
league and the ability of great
quarterbacks to make do with less right
like and so
i just think
really what you're talking about here
when you're talking about that level of
player nothing against cooper cup was a
fantastic player
how hard is it to find a guy like him
you can find other guys like cooper cup
i don't think you can find another guy
like aaron donald albert breer senior
nfl reporter lead content strategist for
the monday morning quarterback it feels
like you got a couple of teams that are
you know they're playing russian
roulette here with their quarterbacking
situations with lamar jackson when do
you sign him kyler murray when do you
sign him if you're the browns what do
you do for insurance if deshawn watson
is going to be traded what are the
niners going to do can you keep jimmy
garoppolo should you keep jimmy
garoppolo rank the order of
uh amber alerts there with these
quarterbacking situations
um i think the cardinals like there's
just
enough warning signs there and it's good
that he showed up but i think their
ability to to get a deal done i think
kyler's shown more of a willingness to
draw a hard line
um than the other players on your list
right like and maybe he even uses
baseball at some point as you know
as a way to draw that line
but i just think like
look like i understand sometimes owners
want to keep their keep their money
invested in the hedge funds for another
six months so they don't pay a guy in
february they pay him in august instead
right like i get that but we've seen so
many examples this off season alone of
how the price is going up on players and
if you wait you're gonna wind up paying
you know a real tax and i think that
that's what's happened with both kyler
and lamar right like with both kylo and
lamar now
by waiting and by being patient here and
by saying we'll get it done when we get
it done
well like the number of quarterbacks
making over 40 million dollars a year
dan has doubled it's gone from three to
six with derek carr matthew stafford and
deshaun watson now all over that
threshold and aaron rodgers is now over
50 million dollars a year and so
like i think that you know both those
situations bear watching because the
market's changed and if either of those
guys decide i'm drawing a hard line at
the watson deal which was fully
guaranteed
well now where do you go because now you
got to put that money in escrow if
you're michael bidwell or um or
or uh steve bashady and so i think
you know because kyler's been willing to
draw a harder line i'd say that's the
one worth watching um but lamar's worth
watching too
cleveland
i mean look you know i i just
no one knows what the suspension is
going to be and so
i think that they've sort of protected
themselves where it's just sort of you
have to let the cards fall where they
may and there's nothing they can really
do to control it
um and i think they like to move baker
off the roster
but they've set it up so like if they
have to they can i think it's going to
come down to how much money they're
willing to swallow but if they have to
they've got the cap space to carry him
if they need to and maybe it winds up
being if deshaun were to somehow be
suspended for the whole year
like he becomes the insurance policy
because like i've been told they were
willing to pay like nine or ten million
dollars of his salary to trade him
before the draft
you know maybe this just kind of becomes
turnabout where it's like okay like now
we have him here so deshawn's gone the
whole year then you know we have him at
least in place maybe we can talk him
back onto the roster and then the jimmy
thing i think it's just going to be a
matter of
who is willing to
come in and redo his contract and the
niners have already you know talked to
other teams about giving them permission
to talk to jimmy and his agents about
his his financials so i would say
in a long-winded way and i think i just
took up two or three minutes of your
time there dan uh murray and jackson
first and then uh
and then i would say mayfield after that
and maybe garoppolo uh
fourth help me understand the
approach logic of rusty hardin who's
representing desean watson that you go
on a houston radio station and then you
say
getting a happy ending isn't illegal
um
feels like he's hurting his client i
don't know how you help your client like
i would want my attorney to shut up
don't try to win any court of public
opinion i want you to just win in court
not court of public opinion
i had i had the same thought um you know
and like i i asked around about this at
the end of last week with some lawyer
friends of mine like why would you do
why would you go public in this sort of
way
the answer i got uniformly was because
there's a narrative out there that you
feel like needs to be corrected
and it sort of makes me wonder how much
they knew about the 24th suit and
whether or not they were trying to get
in front of that and maybe it relates to
their defense on the 24 suit that's the
only thing i can think of you know um
and obviously there's graphic detail on
that one and we don't know who's telling
the truth there are very few people that
know who's telling the truth but
like i like i i like that's the only
thing i can think of is that if there's
a narrative out there
that they feel like that rusty feels
like needs to be corrected that's why
you would do this and maybe it's even
getting in front of it with potential
jurors like you hope that a potential
juror hears your message now so it sort
of sinks in so by the time they're
sitting there
you know all in all likelihood in 2023
like they already have that piece of it
you know they already know that piece of
it that's the only that's the only thing
i came across over the last few days
that explains it otherwise i'd be with
you i i just it doesn't make a ton of
sense why you would be so public in
saying the things that he said but it is
and i don't know how else to say this
but is a happy ending while he says it's
not illegal is it prostitution
right and i and i think that that's i
mean
like i think that that's
like a road that this could wind up
going down in court you know like
this is a complicated case stan i mean
there's a lot of
like tentacles here and and i think you
know if this thing gets to court what
you're gonna find
is
like one suit isn't identical to the
next you know and so
like they're dealing with that they're
gonna be dealing with you know now 24
you know different accusers
and i i think it would be
i'm not saying there isn't a pattern
there but i think it would be wrong to
think that there isn't
i think it'll be wrong to think that
every single case is going to be
analogous to the next and so
like i think what you're talking about
could be rusty harden
making that sort of assertion in a
handful of the cases and saying this is
where we this is this is where this
handful of cases is
like
that'd be my sense of it i just
obviously i think you know like anything
like this like all like
all sexual assault cases are
are complicated and i don't think
like
i don't think this is going to be any
exception i i think there's going to be
differences from one case to the next if
this thing does go to court thank you
albert good to talk to you all right
thanks dan that's albert breer you can
read the monday morning quarterback now
he's the senior nfl reporter lead
content strategist